[Music]
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
that's the way butts away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called a butt the slow you cook it
the more juice it is and it's great for
big parties because you just come along
and get your fork and shred it a
delicious Smoky mayonnaise and in a way
onions into half and half again okay I'm
Gonna Leave the roots on okay because I
want this to sit underneath the pool
it gives a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you
um to crush the garlic we're gonna make
a really nice little paste
okay
[Music]
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more Crush
come on
Cut there now this
there's a beauty paprika smoke paprika I
love it so three nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons of brown
sugar
salt please and pepper
[Laughter]
so I'm gonna form a nice paste now olive
oil in
what's that I want some thyme in there
so we've got a sort of fragrant rub time
stalks underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now this is where you've got to be
really quick
okay
I've rubbed that massage it in almost
that's exactly that
honestly just drizzle a little touch of
olive oil on top of that for me
I keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right it's quite easy as
well to make it's very easy five and a
half to six hours in the oven at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts Meg
and I are gonna pimp some shop bought
mayonnaise
I don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you can twist
yeah there's so many things so many
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper
and
a little touch of Honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste
I love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge great for open sandwiches yeah
you can use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
a nice spoon of mustard
[Music]
that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finally diced sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer
mashed potatoes are equally delicious
served hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off I'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay
never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing
fresh sugar in teaspoon of sugar please
die
cider vinegar
finally chopped it up
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right Little Puppy
Bowl please nice and gently
half of them in the middle please
and stop and then mix that up with me
a little taste
so good and it's a kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
Chipotle now let me be the pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious
before we go to the table just a little
bit honestly
don't tell mum thank you awesome
incredible so good you promised me you
don't give the recipe to your boyfriend
that's good
[Music]
this is my ultimate easy
Hearty dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw deliciously yummy dishes
that will have your family friends and
work buddies coming back for more right
[Music]
I love this
Lily blew my head off we're creating
barbecue style beef brisket with crunchy
coleslaw and sweet potato wedges which
will be right up her Street
Holly
now you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket
look at it beautiful it was a very tough
cut of meat so it needs to be cooked
slowly so it gets really nice and tender
barbecuing it outside we're gonna
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're going to cook it in the
oven okay so mustard powder okay here we
have some celery seed
next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here human two again
nice good now this one
can pepper absolutely right right two
teaspoons of that in there as well good
now what I want you to do
fresh pepper on there
I'll give that a little mix roll up your
little sleeves and then
I want you
to rub
all that spice into the brisket
almost like you're massaging in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice SO gas on roast and tray on
what we've got to do now with all those
spices is sear them in a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil into the tray
well done okay let's get nice and hot
now you get your brisket
all that spice
throw that in there nicely okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices yep all that spice left on the
plate
we're gonna use yeah
I want you to get the onions nice and
carefully slice them down not too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell those spices now
good girl thank you
[Music]
Sam Holly
was homework that bad no the onions oh
no don't rub your eyes don't rub your
eyes
we've got the color
look on the brisket okay yeah
yeah take that out literally for 30
seconds
okay onions into the tray please
nice
you see it's starting to smell slightly
barbecuing already give that a little
stir
nice
now one nice tablespoon of brown sugar
what does the brown sugar do dad for the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my Bailey's in please
good girl yes please price we'll take
over
careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon of tomato puree roast that
off at the bottom of the tray you can
really rub it in amongst the onions good
girl now look at the color of those
onions
right now time for a little drink
the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there I'll put
mine here good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball okay now this is
where it gets really exciting I want you
to lift the brisket up and put it on top
of the onions in she goes
good girl
and then I want you to pour the stock
all the way around please I'm using beef
stock but it will work with chicken
stock or even vegetable stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil and just pinch
in the ends
found that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it Cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
laughs
job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoke paprika dried oregano cayenne
pepper and mix spice mix done now simply
cut your sweet potatoes into wedges
tossing olive oil and thoroughly cover
with the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh now look at that so we can leave that
to rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
mayonnaise this time we're gonna do it a
little different so I'd like to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
place all of it and start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up nice little touch
salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar in there okay as
I shred this okay I'd like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix it in at the same time and then
you fold that in there as I start
shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now for
the white
so got that nice vinegary tartness for
the slaw and the yogurt keeps it nice
and fresh
last little bit in
one more little thing
so
put some nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give it this nice light
onion flavor
so Chinese in
[Music]
is that now taste it with the chives in
there
Mmm delicious so
I would like you
to fill up the bowl I'm going to very
carefully lift out my brisket
comes drunk it's been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
and start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first
for anybody that is so good that
taste
delicious
see all that wonderful flavor in there
last job is to create an incredibly
quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in then add
inside of vinegar and you've got a
brilliant Tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it
to go in the gravy pot
and that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my darling
is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me I've got the
brisket wow
Let's Go Darling well done by the way
thank you this is a real American Beauty
gorgeous low and slow cooked barbecue
beef brisket with three potato wedges
and yogurt coleslaw
Megan Jack hi Tilly big deep Smoky
flavors that bring the taste of the
American South to your kitchen
who'd like some coleslaw
and who'd like some gravy thank you but
it's spicy and slightly barbecuing how's
the brisket really good it's amazing
especially with the gravy
and what do you think of
this one's pretty good you think so yeah
if you're not as good as mine but I can
feel
a lot of competition
and amongst the Ramsay girls good job
foreign